-And you were so sharply
dressed, as always.
-Thank you.
-Yet a little toned down
from your last time.
We had fun the last time you
were here, because, let's admit.
You were dressed a little bi
like maybe a Bond villain.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It was a little much.
This was a turtleneck, too
and I got nervous and I cut it
in the dressing room.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I took some scissors to i
because I was like,
"He's just gonna have a go at me
and I can't do it like that.
-And you can't go
back-to-back turtlenecks.
You can get away with it once,
but when it becomes a trend,
then you're the turtleneck guy
-Yeah, I don't want to be
the turtleneck guy.
-Congrats -- you
and your lovely wife, Jill
you had
your 10-year anniversary.
-We did, yes.
-Went to Hawaii.
-We did, yeah.
The island of Lanai.
-And you went on a catamaran
-Yeah.
-Like, was this
like a sunset cruise?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's
exactly what it was.
It was a sunset cruise.
And I don't know if you guys
could see that photo.
It was so beautiful.
And the island of Lanai
was great.
And this is actually
the "before" picture.
Do you have that other picture
over there?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so -- You see that?
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah, isn't that nice?
Yeah, 10-year
wedding anniversary.
So what's actually
happening here
is we were puking off
the back of the boat.
[ Laughter ]
-The water does look
a little rough
when you focus on the water.
-Yeah, it was
extraordinarily rough.
-How quickly into the ride did
you know it was problematic?
-About 30 minutes in,
I was like, "This is --
This is gonna be
a problem for me."
-Uh-huh.
-And I looked over at my wife,
Jill, and she was already, like,
clinging to
the side of the boat.
And the other funny thing abou
that is those photos
were taken by somebody that was,
like, a fan of the show.
[ Laughter ]
I was not with the person
who took those photos.
And then, afterwards,
they were like,
"Hey, I got some photos
of you guys."
And I was like, "I was pukin
off the back of the boat."
[ Laughter ]
It was -- No, it was like,
it was crazy and, I was,
and she -- she did
a great job though.
She rallied and went to dinner
with some friends of ours
afterwards.
-Oh, you couldn't even
go to dinner after?
-Oh, no, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
No, I was finished. I said
"I'm gonna go to the room.
And I literally
walked in the room --
I have no idea why I did this,
but this is a true story -
I peeled off all my clothe
down to my undies and I got --
and I got cozy deep into
the covers and I snuggled in
and I put Roberta Flack
on my phone
and I listened to
"Killing Me Softly."
[ Laughter ]
And "the first time,
I ever saw your face."
-Those were the -- Yeah.
-And I don't know
if you guys know that song
Probably the greatest song
ever written.
-Yeah.
-But that was a true story
I actually did that.
I don't know why,
but for some reason --
-Everybody says if you're
seasick, listen to that song
[ Laughter ]
-Listen to Roberta Flack.
-Yeah, that's very normal.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Was this before
or after the trip?
You guys took out UTVs
in the same trip.
Was this, like,
after the seasickness?
-No, that was before.
-Yeah, you look
very robust here.
-Yeah, yeah, we were still doing
well at that point.
I don't know why
those didn't make us sick
because that was way bumpier
but I think it was
because there was a lot of
starting and stopping.
-Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, once you're on the boat,
you're just screwed.
-Do you think we look
pretty cool there?
-I do think
you guys look pretty cool.
How -- Is this another one
that a rando took it of you,
or was this one that you knew --
-Yeah, no, those were
our friends.
[ Laughter ]
Took that photo,
but, yeah, it's important
to look cool if you're gonna
drive around on a UTV.
Also, you want to look cool.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, I mean, that's
the whole point is to look cool.
-But you don't want to get
covered in dust either,
so you put on the coveralls.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you just jam Roberta
Flack and drive over the -
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.